hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play ah it's ok now
this game is obviously still under
development and there's a little Android
thingy here but anyway this has been
suggested many many times so I'll give
it a go here let's see just want to talk
about this break in business I already
checked it for you you could get at
least 20 bags I have the front door key
anything else I was me I suppose make a
map that place is huge
good luck have fun ok I guess I'm gonna
rob some place well that's always good
the life of off criminal is high-paying
and worth it totally do it I suggest it
to everyone I'm a role model ok anyway
so I got a little bedroom here it's all
black and white it was ha it was easy
find a bag right where I woke up in why
was I asleep here anyway
oh it's weird it's like things are black
and white until I get close to him
that's actually really cool alright so
something about a map oh hello well
that's a shock EMAP man come on could
you make a worse one ok here oh hello
nothing so far
what is that Oh TV you freaking out a
bit don't do that don't do that okay no
I I just push him okay
hello old men and ladies don't you look
dignified and Noble okay so I'm guessing
that there's some form of a monster
that's gonna go Santa aha
two of 20 mm whoever my friend is is an
[ __ ] stop shaking everything okay I
have I got an I guess that's the
namesake of the game that's three of 20
ma'am 20 bags that's a lot of bags okay
anyway see what we can get don't know
what we're looking for or running from I
see another bag yeah
anything gonna go weird yep
things are gonna start shaking got
another eye oh hello baby
haha what was that looks like a ballet
dancer she was pretty she was
I died I guess what was that sir I just
saw running hey I thought I was actually
in danger there I didn't know that uh
see the map
ITV's touka freaked out on me yep i
didn't know that i was being haunted by
such a delightfully delicate beautiful
flower this cannot leave yet need to
find 20 bags okay I didn't know I was
gonna run anyway that room was kind of
closed off so anyway
Oh methinks I'm gonna enjoy this game oh
stop being such a baby three bags you
run run running another bags come on
baby we got some ropes and some mood
moody lighting in here come on in baby
there's nothing to be afraid of I just
got a little candle here what did I blow
that out oh come on man no need for that
I came back on hmm one of those trick
candles okay so let's carry on I hope
it's the same ghost each time cuz
otherwise this is be awkward very
awkward this place is big another bag
five out of twenty okay good thing it
didn't tell me to run up here cuz I
would be boned just like I am many other
times no no baby yeah hmm I
that's cute to see war Hey oh you
startled me baby oh come on I don't know
what what the hell did I see there's a
bag give me that all right man I'm I'm
bad at this game it's very easy for the
monster sure to give me run that way
I love baby huh no ah am I supposed to
go baby you're just so persistent oh
yeah oh yeah okay so I got to I got
three wait did I just get a third one I
don't think Oh Sam to see the map I know
the map okay so this lady is like
awfully persistent no I hear I mean who
wouldn't be if any of you my lovely
fangirls out there saw me on the street
corner wouldn't you just make a mad dash
to try to get to me huh just snag that
right out of the fridge yeah I'm just so
irresistible is that a stain on the wall
oh man this place is big why are some
candles lit and some not oh those aren't
candles those are candle like light
bulbs well nothing to be scared of here
nothing like being haunted by a sexy
ghost still don't know why I need to see
cuz seeing apparently drew her right to
be so I'm not exactly sure why I do that
all right all done here let's go to the
other side hmm actually I'm trying to
win I'm not trying to run headfirst into
the ghost okay guess we're good I guess
we just run until it says not to run
anymore
hmm all right not a fun not a sexy ghost
god damn these sexy ghosts everywhere
just imagine a man in his underwear
hello now he's on
anyone know what I'm talking about there
[Music]
I'm still running Oh God see stop it
stop with the running I'm trying to run
you're not giving me anywhere to go piss
piss yeah look at all these I'm okay
okay I got 13 somehow I found my way
back to this room
oh I know she she's trying to stay away
from me she tried to be coy now but she
knows she knows where she was and she
wants me
oh yeah come back baby come back don't
go back huh
I'm actually close to winning so please
don't hey hey you stop that now
oh this is the way I shouldn't have
followed the smoke okay this is the way
I came from I need to go this way to get
the hell out of here
oh no way this is the way I came from
what did that murder River ha ha
everything looks the same I'm so
confused Oh
locked find the combination up poopie ah
where the hell am I gonna find a
combination chalkboard got it
15 of 20 this is the closest I've come
to victory is that I know play okay all
right anyway should be a bad place to
get cornered in so let's not let's not
and say we did
let's not and say we didn't Oh what the
hell it's a second door this bull I'm
gonna get killed I'm gonna get murdered
I've stopped very very close without the
combination or something I don't like
this I do not like this I have a feeling
she's very near by who there's actually
color in here hi I wore ah piss hell is
that okay let's just go I think I got a
combination I'm not sure but I think I
did yes oh god I'm 18 and 20 where the
hell is the other ones I don't know I
think I've been everywhere except maybe
downstairs yeah I think if I manage to
go downstairs yeah here you sure lady
I'll be with you in just a second baby
I'll be with you all and it'll be so
good you you know you know it will but I
just need to finish up one Oh a rat I
just need to finish up one more thing
baby then up then I will devote 100% of
my attention to you
Nikes I'm cornered that was the last one
wait a minute
am I done here am I done how do I get
out oh I need to go back up wait what
was that wait what's that there can't be
another one 21 of 20 oh I can get at
least 20 bags that's right whoa
Jamis what's this sound ha yes so much
moola I'm rich I'm rich I just got to
get out of here now come on don't screw
it up now markiplier how do I get out of
here don't press that Q button you know
that's suicide
you know it's Jewish time how do I get
out of here I just got to get back up
one floor run now it's so close
run run on AAPIs over oh [ __ ] me oh no
Gary run I'm trying to run go away lady
go away how do I get back out
I'm lost again I had the right way and
you I got greedy I got too many bags
let's try this one more time I must
sprint through it as fast as I can I'm
gonna go to the basement first there
were a ton of bags in the basement all
right let's try this again I'm gonna win
this I'm not gonna let this be me I'm
not gonna let this be me let's go this
way first because this is uh this is the
only dead-end in this area I don't know
what the cute the eye thing does - I
hear ya
lady all right you're Purdy but tear see
I gotta go about my business I gotta go
buy my business okay all right all right
you just leave me alone for a little bit
oh come on she come from she's quick she
is quick so I guess she just runs like
specific patterns in this area and I
guess like it's it's not really like how
do I does the cue just tell me where she
is
it's out that does Oh does it just shows
me where she's floating so I can try to
avoid her later okay all right I guess
that's kind of useful I guess let's
collect the eyeballs that way if I I can
wait until I know when I need to run to
the exit maybe I don't know I know I can
beat this I know I can beat this not
gonna be me as fun as you is they're not
gonna be me don't know why I can't cross
under that ladder maybe the bad luck I
don't want any bad luck okay I think she
was in the roof or in the upstairs so if
I collect all this stuff down here the
only reason she caught me is because I
looked back and ran out of sprint that
was just dumb on my part I could have
easily won that okay get him ahhh get
him ahhh get him ahhh get him ahhh get
them all get them all shut up yeah
locked find a key where the hell is a
key I don't know probably upstairs
everything's all convoluted in this
so-called mansion manor mansion I don't
even know what it did oh she's nearby
where she where is she
Richie I just got to go upstairs got to
get out here okay go upstairs
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha you can't beat me
I'm too smart for you too smart too
brave too strong
ah there's the key well if I needed that
stupid light okay combination all sorts
of stuff here just need six more and I'm
in the winner's circle lady lady you
stop that now two of them just need
three more and I'm good I think they're
obviously their pride definitely gonna
be three more up here stop stop that
seriously up oh yeah oh yeah okay look
now let's let's not even dick around a
bit wait isn't there another way out
yeah I think this is another way out
finger this way oh yeah oh yeah
[Music]
Oh feel great
ah okay so that's that was actually
really good I liked that a lot
um the mechanics of the boss can be
tweaked a bit but obviously these are
still in development there's still a lot
of work to be done I like it I like it a
lot it's a it's a new interesting um
it's a different take on the collection
mechanic and I think it I think it has a
lot of potential to be developed into
something else so thank you paulina link
is in the description below if you want
to play for yourself try to get more
than 20 try to get all of them see if
there's a different reward so alright so
be sure to credit her she may have did a
great job making this so thank you
everybody so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos it I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]